[Music]
okay it's another monday where we talk
about how american city is reeling from
another violent weekend in oregon police
searching for three suspects who
threatened a ralph lauren
outlet store worker with a gun after
being confronted about shoplifting and
in philadelphia reckless street racers
damage roads right outside of city hall
doing those donuts look at that
[Music]
yeah
yep former nypd officer and unfiltered
host dan bongino has been supplied that
video prior to this segment and wants to
react
dan
crime's still a major issue almost fair
on every candidate's punch list if they
want to get into office
that to me is heartening but this is out
of control
yeah i mean think about how we got here
isn't it disturbing we're even having
this conversation you know i'm doing a
segment on on my podcast today called
you know things conservatives knew
months ago right um common sense stuff
and one of the things we knew months if
not years if not decades ago as
conservatives was you know when you
enforce the law brian
shocker you get less law-breaking i mean
the fact that there are liberals
watching the show today who are stunned
by this assertion says everything about
the state of america you need to hear i
mean we we actually lived through the
high crime and chaos eras right in la
new york we're still living through it
now in chicago and we know what worked i
mean many of you are new yorkers brian
you've lived in new york a lot of your
adult life remember what happened back
then we had the david dinkins era crime
exploded rudy giuliani comes in with
jack maple and bill bratton the police
commissioner in the first step and they
say hey i got this crazy idea like if
someone jumps a turnstile maybe we
should arrest them for jumping the
turnstile and you know what happened
brian a lot of the guys they arrested
and detained had warrants for other
crimes and they jumped the turnstile
because they were going to commit
another crime on the train which then
didn't happen sure now that we're not
doing that crime's exploding you have to
understand it's only liberals scratching
their heads conservatives are like okay
you defunded the police and crime
exploded yeah yeah we get it right but
you're also forgetting uh dan here in
new york state you know they they redid
the criminal justice stuff and now it's
almost impossible to get arrested where
they you know they actually
prosecute yeah
yeah yeah and and and what here's why
this is such a big deal i mean it's
outside the obvious like if you keep
criminals in jail they won't commit
crime i get the obvious point but again
you know liberals watch the show so you
have to talk really slow right when you
look at criminology research there's a
very small thank god by the way there's
a very small percentage of the
population that commits the overwhelming
majority of the crimes forgive me i
don't have the exact number but it's
small you know less than 20 of the
population commits roughly about 80
percent of the crime so when you get
even half of those people a quarter or
even a tenth of those people steve off
the streets it's it's not directly
proportional it's almost like geometric
the decrease in crime because if you
have one guy committing 10 crimes over
the source of the re week it's not a
one-for-one deal you get him off the
street that's 10 less crimes that happen
next week again i mean i know leftists
are listening so math and stuff are hard
but that's why broken windows policing
work and that's why things like bail
reform where we let people out 10
seconds after they commit a violent
crime that's why you don't see you see
this explosion that again is is
geometric not just arithmetic
tell us about the fox nation patriot
awards that are going to be hosted down
there in florida where you live and i
know you'll be on stage
i know i love it i've been at you know
last year we had to go kind of digital
with it but i was there with you all
remember the first year we were down we
were in tampa it was awesome and yeah
and remember all the you know we had the
hockey coach who gave the great speech i
mean finally like an award show for
people that matter you know instead of
like hollywood elitist so i'll be there
i'll like i said last week i'll be there
with bells on maybe no bells but i'll be
acting like i'll have bells on it's
going to be awesome get your tickets and
uh say hello to everybody i'm happy to
do it i can't wait much needed red white
and blue event uh dan so i look forward
to seeing you down there
yeah me too guys it was great thanks for
having me in studio this week for the
hospitality i appreciate it it's fun to
be up there we don't regret it
it was good to see you in person good
all right for tickets go to
foxnation.com patriot awards thanks dan
and pete says hosting will be great